I think that as explainers of science
we have a political obligation to think
very carefully about how we will be
misunderstood if we're misunderstood and
I think that in this area the proper
risks and misunderstanding are huge
you've just given a very clear
articulation of the view that there's no
real design because no process in nature
is a proper designer this is a view that
the Richard also shares and he even came
up with the term designoid object of our
and I heard these guys talking about the
marvels of a cell he decided to sell
they were they just seen the video or
heard a lecture or something about the
intricacies of what goes on inside the
single cell now one of them look the
other said why you see all of those
amazing machines and you deserve as how
can it possibly be true and my jaw
dropped because these were not rednecks
these were harvard medical students and
what i realize them and i have other
examples of this is that the idea is out
there in the world that evolutionary
biologists that it is very much in their
interest to downplay the marvelousness
of nature and as i don't know there's no
design in nature not really and so any
example of brilliant design in nature is
an embarrassment to science i think
that's exactly wrong i think that we
should recognize that what evolution
accomplishes and development is
stupendously clever now that means that
means that the process the
non-supernatural natural process is
properly called
a design process because we can actually
compare real design which is what we see
in the in the
with Sudha my favorite example of pseudo
design is when the cartoonist like
Sidney Harris as a cartoon of science
and he's got a blackboard and it's all
covered with fantastic formula and we're
all supposed to understand that that's
some deep kind of physics and it's just
gibberish that's designoid it's a parent
design the design in nature is not only
real design it is typically better than
what any human engineers can come up
with the the optimization of energy use
and so it is typically far exceeds what
what the paradigmatic designers can come
up with Dan's point is all based upon
the idea that natural design is just as
good as human design and maybe it is but
that's not the only consideration
there's also the provenance of the two
of the two designers hallux were
suggesting that actually fundamentally
even human design is a kind of natural
selection but natural design has no
foresight human design can look ahead
and say if we go on polluting the
atmosphere or get the global warming in
a centuries time there's going to be a
disaster not just for me personally but
for the whole of humanity of a pelican
ecosystem that's looking ahead of time
and Nature doesn't do that nature
optimizes in the short-term for the
individual actor that's doing it now
that's a very very important difference
if you've if you assumed that if you use
the same word design for biological
design and for human design then you
would get the wrong answer when faced
with conundrums about natural design
which people do everyday in biology
there are people who think that because
adaptation is a good thing therefore
whatever is going to be a good thing in
the human sense will evolve that it
won't species may drive themselves
extinct by going hell-for-leather like a
gallery the swine um over over the cliff
of the short
adaptation and so I think there's us I
doesn't have to be the word design I'd
but but something which expresses both
the fact that biological design is very
very good there by the way not perfect
it's very very good and expresses the
fact that it doesn't come about how the
same process in in particular you'll get
the wrong answer if you're a biologist
who assumes something like well actually
if teleology
you